il est mort le 18 décembre 2001 il y a
20 ans Gilbert Bécaud ses 55 ans de
carrière des tubes un swing inégalée une
cravate à pois chiches et surtout un
amour inconditionnel pour l'Olympia
de l'Europe
[Musique]
la salle de spectacle
il y a dansé
pendant toute sa carrière
sur Seine dans la salle le
[Musique]
jeudi
une fois sur scène il interprète une de
cette dernière chanson écrite par le
parolier Pierre Delanoë son titre
Nathalie
la souris
[Musique]
Gilbert Bécaud reviens à l'Olympia
chaque année ou presque en 1967 c'est
encore ici qu'il commence à tourner et
même s'il a l'habitude de se produire
pour cette première le trac et le
rendez-vous c'est
toujours commencer par la seconde parce
que
c'est
ça fait mal ça c'est pénible entre
l'Olympia Iveco l'histoire d'amour
continue la célèbre salle de spectacle
va même jusqu'à inspirer l'artiste en
1993 il compose la chanson il est à moi
un titre en hommage à son lieu fétiche
en voici un extrait c'était en 1997
[Musique]
1997 toujours l'Olympia ouvre ses portes
après des mois de travaux Gilbert Bécaud
n'aurais raté pour rien au monde
l'inauguration de la nouvelle salle vous
l'aurez deviné le premier artiste à 6
produire c'est lui quand il va rentrer
il va dire mais ils n'ont pas ils n'ont
rien touché alors tout a été cassé un
petit morceau et tout est
génial le dernier concert de Gilbert
Bécaud à l'Olympia en 1999 au total des
produits 31 x hardcore le jour de sa
mort sur la façade de l'Olympia 3 mots
Salut Gilbert Bécaud ultime hommage aux
chanteurs disparus
[Musique]